everyone wants to know if you actually
shaved your head and if you really use a
flipper
so i know the answers to both of those
questions so instead
what was it like doing the bald cap
process
and then what was required vfx wise in
order to
do the flipper part okay so the bald cap
was one of the coolest things i've ever
done i was walking around and i was like
i'm gonna shave my head if they wanted
me to shave my head for season two
for the whole time i would i would do it
it was so cool a long time in hair and
makeup they actually flew me to sydney
which is where i'm from
which was great so i got to say hi to
mum and dad but they flew me to sydney
to do
um like a cast over my head i actually
have a photo of it on my instagram
and that's something that was really
hard for me because it's kind of
claustrophobic you're
completely covered in like this silicon
sort of
i don't even know what it is that
creates a mold of your entire
like head to chest and you're in there
for like 20 minutes
like trying to breathe through like
these tiny little holes which was
hard but it was it was fun it was a lot
of fun they
were so good at their job the people
that worked there so it was great
then they made a ball cap from that
shape of my head
and then added each individual hair onto
it like every single hair on there was
like
put in one by one amazing so like
wow um then when we were doing it i was
in hair makeup for like four and a half
five hours getting it on
um then blending it in with my skin i
wasn't able to like
eat breakfast or anything because you
can't chew with the
with the yeah with it on so it was it
was hard but it was so much fun i just
loved walking around in it
um it was great and the teeth
the flipper was like they just yes
when they just put two little dots on my
teeth through the camera like not on my
actual teeth
and just in post edited them out which
is amazing because even when i'm moving
and talking they were just like
going shot by shot frame by frame and
removing those teeth which is
really cool and then i had a um
flipper that had the teeth on it and
then a flipper that didn't have the
teeth on it so i had something to click
in
and something to click out but they were
two different things so every time i was
like okay we have to have the
flipper in this shot because she's
already taken it out so i have the one
with
the teeth on it and they cut and i have
to put them on with the with no teeth on
it so i can click it in
because i actually have teeth there so i
couldn't click in a proper one so it was
very like kind of stopped starting but
by the end of season one we
everyone was so used to the process and
they were like okay we were all like
pros at it and we just knew exactly what
to do
but at the beginning it was like wait
very confusing